hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to guess
what I was looking at the lineup and it
turns out the very next movie I'm gonna
review is the Avengers I know can you
believe it right one of the most hyped
up comic-book movies of all time I
didn't even know was finished yet but
apparently we're gonna take a look at it
and see how it holds up are you ready I
know I sure am let's take a sneak peak
at what we're in store for
[Music]
all right a little background the
Avengers is not based on one of the
best-selling comic books with some of
the greatest superheroes of all time
it's instead based on a British pop VI
agent at his brothel of alternating hot
crumpets I guess it was sort of like a
James Bond meets the prisoner sort of
thing and before I get a million angry
emails no I've never actually seen the
show but hey a movie should be good
despite the fact if you've seen the show
at all and depending on what I've heard
about this film yeah
where's great let's dive right into the
Avengers we start off with secret agent
John Steve played by ray Fiennes walking
through an obstacle course training him
in case everybody in the frigging world
goes fucking blood hungry well done
steed my pleasure
[Music]
macaroons for mother and who is mother
you may ask well it turns out that
mother in this movie is a man well not
quite that man but he is the head of the
Ministry of Elite intelligence he's
played by that British guy who always
seems to be in everything but you never
bothered to take the time to figure out
what his name is
and if you're really ballsy enough to
actually say what his real name is in
the comments below
fuck you the rest of the world knows him
as that British guy whose name we can't
remember he sends out a message to
another agent Emma Peel play by uma
thurman who's just moseying around the
house in her everyday ungodly expensive
Chinese dress oh come on ladies we all
know you do that
please answer the telephone did they
really need to send her a package saying
answer the phone doesn't that kind of go
without saying if the phone rings you
answer it you really need to waste the
postage to tell her this
what other basic commands do you think
she has to be told
[Music]
turn off the stove open the microphone
tell Sean Connery it's too late for this
is own but he could still back out of
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen so
she enters into the gentlemen's club
which is most unorthodox no women not in
boodles not since 1762 really she then
meets up every since probably up now
with John Steed another woman inside
boodles since 1762 oh you mean like the
direct rule she was given to meet up
with you even though women aren't
allowed in this place breaking the rules
that's not her fault you chose a
location that makes no fucking sense now
that we've settled the matter of titles
will you kindly explain why you wish to
meet me I didn't mother did mother
mother
so as they drive off to meet mother you
may notice something very odd about the
people of London in this movie there's
no people of London in this movie what
is this 20 days later I've never seen
the play so abandoned maybe they are
they were filming this shithole and
evacuate the city to save on therapy
bills deep so pill talks about how she
was working on a weather shield that was
being built as a defense mechanism the
only problem is the research lab has
been blown up by an all too familiar
face
you're our chief suspect I'm innocent of
course why would I sabotage my own
project
tell us you'll be allowed of privilege
to prove your innocence if you didn't
blow up Prospero find out who did really
you have video evidence that she is the
culprit
and you're actually gonna let her solve
the case this seems a tad backwards
you'd like us to work as a team hmm you
mean I have to trust you the video
Carrie you dumb broad he should be
having a hard time trusting yo you think
mrs. peel is dangerous father all in my
report wait wait wait
father the woman's name is father let me
see if I understand this ministry
correctly you have a woman named father
a man named mother a package instructing
agents how to pick up a phone a message
telling a woman to meet in a place where
no women are allowed and most likely
letting a criminal with hard evidence
against her solve her own crime does
anything in this agency makes sense
everything is totally friggin upside
down Oh while we're at it well we
thought some more confusing names yeah
we'll have the information drop it off
to agents sister who will then drop it
off - agent brother right after handing
it over to agent cat who relayed the
message to mr. dog and mr. dog will
confirm it with agent black Craig so
glad things worked so sensibly around
here my theory goes mrs. peel may be ill
revenge is a possible motive she
certainly fits our perfo it is not only
possible it is essential so they talk
about what they're going to do to solve
the case well swordfighting why well see
if you can guess artificially creating
new weather systems
if you haven't figured it out yet this
whole entire movie is based on one
friggin joke they're polite they perform
incredibly dangerous stunts and react
with a calm friendly retort that's it
that's where all the humor in this movie
comes from so what do you attribute your
other achievements my father always
wanted a boy I fail to see the
connection now let's take out the fact
that this is all based on blunt joke and
a particularly weak one at that and ask
one question if nobody in this movie
becomes passionate or excited about what
they're doing why should we why should
we care if they make it out of a
situation when clearly they have as much
energy and drive as Victorian senior
citizens or do they ever become
interested in anything nope they just
talk politely about it throughout the
entire movie marvelous weather another
sort of day to be stuck in town I think
we ought to get away in the country
about it mrs. P depends what you have in
mind well I'm a nature lover so whatever
comes naturally I'd say they were just
right for honesty would you I would
indeed indeed I will well let's see if
Sean Connery one of the reigning kings
of cool could spice things up a bit
he plays an ex-agent named dr. August a
winter and the adventures which I just
realized I never called the Avengers in
this movie nor are they ever avenging
anything have a feeling his obsession
with the weather might have something to
do with the case oh yes the Mongoose we
miss a boy when Nana taught me the
naming of the clouds cover band nothing
beats a good washing my dad even Sean
Connery and all his coolness can't save
this snorefest on top of that he's not
even that smooth he comes a process sort
of an awkward horny old man I always
admire a woman who is literally
logically inclined don't you
please don't do you mind one should
never fear don't worry I have a dozen
other Roger more pickup lines mr. Steve
comes across an unusual sight a sudden
snowstorm accompanied by mrs. peel and
her Queen of Narnia cosplay he then
waits out fighting mrs. peel attending
to his wounds does this freak him out at
all now you tried to shoot me didn't you
I would never shoot you not without my
reason I remember it clearly but luckily
my trouble waistcoat was bulletproof boy
if you really cool it maybe they showed
us this vest either being tested out or
explained like any other good spy flick
but hell with that as we got more
bantering to do I'm the sort that
doesn't take no for an answer I think
that would depend entirely on the
question mrs. peel nursing an invalid
isn't my idea of fun after all what a
disappointing yes so they go to a secret
underground company called Wonderland
whether we're they love much welcome to
Wonderland weather here in our London
headquarters
turn it to the Grateful Dead's teddy
bear picnic I'm sorry you can't do that
you can't do that you can't have nothing
but blank characters bland dialog and
bland visuals throughout the entire film
and then suddenly throw this shit at us
you all know who I am and I know all of
you know I guess the idea is supposed to
be that they're all in disguise because
there's such big names but really this
is the best you could come up with what
happened to just a paper bag over the
face or hell even the secure video
conference this just doesn't seem like
the first logical conclusion to cartoons
and in recognition of your work a
generous offer of 1 million dollars
a week which occurred to me while
showing these wines that this might be a
little ridiculous and of course it is my
sad duty to have you the viewer decide
which one of these jokes I shall go with
and the first mean to be making its way
down the runway the always popular
Christopher Walken from the country
bears and of course we have the always
wonderful dark heart reading from Care
Bears to in time for a game of
disappearing bears the desert and of
course from the movie Alaska Charlton
Heston's reading of that famous line I
want that bear very nice so which review
mean would you like me to go with ladies
and gentlemen you have chosen the always
classic bear so the adventures work
their way behind the scenes and in
keeping in character aren't the least
bit weirded out that there's a bunch of
fucking bears walking around
my god I must warn Andy panda Winnie the
poor immediately
[Music]
well looks like somebody's having a bad
bear day mrs. peel
[Music]
movie will you just look at yourself
that was Emma Thurmond in a bear suit
jumping off a building please tell me
somebody at one point finally said hey
this might might be really fucking
spelled red time to pass of August
another visit so steep now believes that
there are two M appeals which makes the
bad guy send out there real serious
weapons now or they just battle this
dumb shit
look out they come directly from dr.
Wily's agent Alice is there to help them
out
let me guess her stick is she's really
polite would you please be so kind as to
hit the brother so they go back to Sean
Connery's house where he has a devious
plan for them both
he fights off mr. Steve just so we can
let him go and run away after capturing
an appeal just so he can let her go and
run away
I'd say that none of this made any
goddamn sense but then again he was
working for the ministry where the
parents aren't even given the right
gender it's obvious - none of this
adding up this calls for more banter a
bachelor's life it's worked quite well
until now don't tell me never met the
right girl there's always the exception
that proves the rule
quite okay I'm just gonna sum up how
every conversation in this movie goes
I'm gonna start seeing something clever
while you finish your sentence witty
retort topped by me winking smile
returned I want mrs. peel interrogation
mrs. peel is under arrest
so they take mrs. peel away when Steve
realizes he needs help from another
secret agent
Brenda told me to accept ISTE okay even
for a movie that had mechanical bees
grannies with guns and ninja teddy bears
this is pretty silly don't worry about
me being invisible learnt the trick in
camouflage until the accident made
rather a mess of things no I'm stuck
away in the basement lucky if I didn't
get the tea trolley yes because lord
knows that invisible man wouldn't be
useful for any indents by work would he
throw them in the archives for a
five-minute cameo it's cool we put him
next to Godzilla in accounting clearly
we have no news for him so Connery makes
his threat to the world leaders that he
will destroy the world if anybody was in
it with his violent Weathermaker if they
don't give in to his demands hundreds of
millions will die they'll drown freeze
you have no choice what exactly are his
demands what was he doing this entire
criminally insane scheme for money what
do you mean he did it for the money he's
a doctor he's already rich
wait you are he clearly has millions of
dollars a hedge maze a ton of useless
expensive collections but apparently
that just isn't enough for him I guess
he wants to save up for buying the
planet Jupiter or something Hey we all
need a hobby the countdown has already
begun
please never zoom in on any gray hair in
that area again I'm trying to eat my
popcorn
so they discover that peel is a clone
and father is a traitor as she throws
mother from the chair and takes both
peels with her to escape in a hot-air
balloon it really isn't
Mother's Day oh please we're writing
such a high note with that once you
never fear being wet line never mind the
beaten man fallen over in a wheelchair
freezing to death you have to save a
woman who they didn't handcuff for some
reason allowing her to climb out and
blow off the below still keeping the
ministry settings to total fucking
retarded aren't you I'm all right and
the other mrs. peel despatched I think
so after they what a shock
banter some more they get ready to plan
their final attack hamster style
here's another no-brainer scene they had
to use the phone booth to get inside his
lair by saying the secret password
welcome
okay so now he's got him there totally
trapped in the cage for him to do
whatever yes right
open the cage are you a freaking moron
the most intelligent thing in this movie
is the fucking eyebrow up don't wait for
me perish the thought
winking smile return so they split up
and tried to destroy Connery's evil
machine mr. steed fights him head-on
while mrs. peel fights a henchman played
by then unknown comedian Eddie Izzard
God at this rate
Oh No look out they playing the stock
footage for Mars Attacks
so in a very bizarre way to go Sean
Connery gets dad by mr. steed and then
struck by lightning
finally - rapture take me away Jesus
I'll never do another movie like this
again
so London returns to its normal crappy
weather no one is still around to see it
Henry finds is realizing playing a half
snake at sperm hybrid chasing a magical
boy suddenly seems like a step up after
this movie
and that's the Avengers what a cup of
dick the sets are dull the dialogue is
dull the characters are dull and it all
hinges on a dull junk if we think just
seems to be on autopilot there's no
passion or drive to anything that
happens you totally forget you saw just
a few minutes after the viewing till
Avengers if you really want to avenge
something bitch this piece-of-shit movie
for making us suffer so much let's just
say it's pretty bad when the god of
thunder a can opener and the Jolly Green
Giant looks much more plausible than
this I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to
[Music]
you
one should never fear being wet